I remember one time when I was on tour
with cat we had went to a restaurant and
we all ordered food right and so I
ordered a steak trying to be different
from everybody else and here comes the
biggest steak I've ever seen in my life
so when it hit the table everybody's
laughing cuz they know you know I eat
like a bird she's not everybody's
laughing pointing at me so cat comes
over and whispers in my ear $500 says
you can't eat that whole steak wow I
think we sat there for extra hour
because I was eating that stink I was
getting that 500 I'm going older I got
it all down and I got that 500 it was
the coolest thing ever is what's so
interesting about cat is like he has
like this camera persona uh-huh but
everything I've heard behind the scenes
has been good he is the biggest heart
he's the greatest guy I've watched him
we did a college one time where I
watched cat throw $5,000 to the audience
and it came to my show and gave a couple
of comics like money see just for
performing big heart the guy is doing
his heart ever I don't care what they
say or you see he's a really nice guy
and very articulate this guy reads a lot
interesting very smart what do you think
that it like why is it like he's seen as
one way but then behind the scenes he's
like I'm clueless I can't figure it out
either yeah I don't know I wish he'd
show that other side people would see I
wish to keep people could see more of
the other side of cat because there's a
really good side to him that a lot of
people don't even know about but if
you're in his circle you know you know
he's got a really big heart good even
when we were on tour my mom passed and
so our course wasn't gonna go on the
road that weekend he paid me as if I
worked that weekend yeah Wow and he
still replaced me so he paid that person
and me Wow yeah so that was like thank
you so much what was your response to
him on v-103 I'm sure you saw Vonda
which actually went on tour with early
on in the game right yeah mark I'm Wanda
me and sure when I first started just
Wanda and Shirley Underwood took me
under there excuse me
took me under their wing I had all the
ten minutes before def Comedy Jam and
they took me under their wing and we
went traveling and they took me all over
the country I was like yeah that was fun
but you know cat had mitten but he said
good things about me no I think Tiffany
getting everything she deserves she's a
really sweetheart she's a great girl
congratulations on your Emmy Tiffany and
she's there to open the doors for us you
know there's no comics have gotten to to
me to where she is right now except for
maybe Whoopi Goldberg and Whoopi you
know she's a neat guy yeah but and they
and congratulations to John Legend the
youngest he got ever incredible yeah Wow
I hope to be the oldest one ever I
believe I want to eat
[Music]